hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben zuschauer viele von euch haben
wir in letzter zeit in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich auch mal ein
visiting my hometown video machen soll
das ist ein video das glaube ich als
erstes vom juli produziert wurde und
zwar hatte sich dort bei google street
view
seine geburtsstadt in schweden
angeschaut
da meine geburtsstadt allerdings ein
ziemlich kleines kaff in ostwestfalen
ist das ziemlich langweilig geworden
wäre habe ich mir gedacht wir besuchen
heute meine erste wohnung
wir befinden uns hier bereits in google
maps ihr seht schon das ist köln hier
ist der rhein hier ist deutsch hier ist
der dom irgendwo und der hauptbahnhof
meine erste wohnung war genau hier genau
hier hno-heilkunde klinik am ring genau
darüber an alle die nicht aus köln
kommen bzw sich dort nicht so richtig
auskennen erstmal die info dass hier ist
die zülpicher straße das ist die straße
wo man sieht schon hier alle möglichen
bars sind entsprechend war die gegend
oft voll mit lauten grölenden
betrunkenen menschen ich habe genau hier
vorne gewohnt da ist mit acht leuten
backwerk mittlerweile früher war da noch
eine bar darauf jeden fall genau hier
gewohnt im sechsten stock das war genau
hier am zülpicher platz also der ist
hier vorne
hier sind baden lang gefahren und hier
sind barren und lang gefahren von daher
war es ziemlich laut in der wohnung ich
zeige euch übrigens gleich auch noch
bilder aus der wohnung also nicht nur
von google maps und gleich street view
sondern nachher auch noch bilder wie es
in der wohnung aus sah also bleibt auf
jeden fall dran ich würde allerdings
sagen dass ich jetzt mal dieses kleine
menschen hier nehmen und einfach mal
hierhin setze auf die jahnstraße
beziehungsweise direkt anzüglicher platz
und man sieht schon ja hier ist einiges
los also das hier ist der zülpicher
platz hier kamen waren immer lang
zwischen rudolfplatz und barbarossaplatz
und hier hinten sind auch bei anlange
kommen da hinten sieht man sogar noch
seine bahnen die sind dann auch nicht
nur alle 10 minuten gefahren sondern
halt wirklich kann man hier hinten ist
auch eine bahn also die sind wirklich
jede 30 sekunden kam davon in eine
richtung der bahn rhein dahin ist auch
eine bahn für ihr seht was da für eine
lautstärke war also hier ist der
zülpicher platz und hier oben das war
meine wohnung also dass
weil es kalt den rücken runter alter das
ist echt krass die sache ist ich hatte
wirklich alles direkt nebenan also die
uni war hier hinten das waren wirklich
200 300 meter hier ist ein basic
biosupermarkt hier waren rewe das hier
war mein fitnessstudio und hier waren
restaurants sie war das sah oscar war da
noch neu
sie hießen der laden wells ecken slay
kasan
das war so ein geiles restaurant schräg
gegenüber das ist auf jeden fall hier da
war anscheinend früher noch dieser oscar
laden als die bilder hier gemacht wurden
hier war eine apotheke hier vorne war
auch eine apotheke hier war seine
eisdiele
daneben wir noch einen salat laden
hinten war sushi asiatisch und hier
waren halt alle bars also ich habe mich
eigentlich nur in meinen 50 metern
draufgehalten es war halt meine erste
wohnung und ich war doch ziemlich stolz
drauf bin allerdings nach acht monaten
weggezogen weil ich halt nach ziemlich
richtig schlafen konnte wegen der ganzen
bahnen und den lauten leuten und ich
konnte auch nicht richtig videos
aufnehmen auf jeden fall war das hier
meine kripp früher und ich würde sagen
das reicht eigentlich jetzt erst mal mit
street view
denn ich habe auch noch bilder
vorbereitet aus der wohnung und zwar
fahren wir als erstes direkt an mit
einem artikel den die bravo tatsächlich
damals vor vier jahren über meine
wohnung hier geschrieben hat war zu
besuch beim super gamer ich konnte noch
nie zocken
keine ahnung warum nehme ich das super
gamer genannt haben willkommen in der
einzimmerwohnung von youtuber luca
besser bekannt als let's play akon
crafter wir haben mich damals angefragt
für ein interview was eigentlich über
youtube gingen war das die zeit war wo
ich echt ein ordentlich gutes wachstum
hatte auf youtube
dann habe ich allerdings gesagt hey wenn
ihr das interview bei mir machen wollte
mich habt 20 quadratmeter wohnungen so
wenn ihr damit drei leuten kommt das
wird echt ziemlich eng
dann meinten die halt hey das ist doch
eine neue story hat unterhalten uns
nicht bei youtube sondern einfach über
deine wohnung und das war eigentlich
ganz lustig die war dann in meiner
wohnung und keiner konnte mir so richtig
rum laufen weil ich hatte halt wirklich
eine 20 quadratmeter wohnung war einfach
so zum verständnis mein komplettes
aufnahme zimmer das er gerade sieht sind
16 quadratmeter also ich hatte noch vier
quadratmeter mehr und hatte auf dieser
fläche dann nicht nur meinen
schreibtisch also mein aufnahmebereich
sondern noch meinen dad meine kleine
küche mein badezimmer eine ankleide auf
20 quadratmetern ich habe halt eher noch
500 euro monatlich für diese wohnung
gezahlt es ist halt köln jeden fall hat
die bravo dann hier in diesem artikel
einiges über meine wohnung und mein
allgemeines wohnverhalten erzählt wie
beispielsweise dass ich sein ziemlich
ordentlicher mensch bin hier wie ich
meinen kühlschrank befülle wenig bei
tips frage die ich brauche im alltag an
das war halt immer
meine mutter gesagt hier geht es auf
jeden fall echt schön geschrieben worden
von der bravo das war auch das erste mal
dass ich so richtig in der zeitung war
das war für mich auch dementsprechend
noch mal etwas besonderes ist allerdings
soll es heute nichts von diesen
zeitungsartikel gehen der hat mich nur
auf diese ganze video idee gebracht
sondern es geht ja um die wohnung und
das hier ist ein panorama fotos von
meiner wohnung so sei die ganze wohnung
wirklich aus einem sie wirkt jetzt
größer als sie wirklich war weiß halt
ein panoramafoto war aber man sieht
schon dass hier waren alles glaube ich
16 17 quadratmeter so um den dreh das
hier war auf jeden fall meine küche hier
das war mein bett und hier sollen
kleiner schrank sondern ein heer
einbauschrank zwar irgendwann alles
alles war von ikea hatte ich meine
ganzen sachen drin
hier war mein schreibtisch mit meinem
kühlschrank und hier weil meine sofaecke
das hier war der ausblick
also echt nice man sieht hier hinten
glaube ich dass uni center hier ist die
herz jesu kirche heißt sie glaube ich
und hierhin ist halt immer die sonne
untergegangen also es war wirklich es
war wirklich ein schöner ausblick man
konnte die wohnung auf jeden fall echt
ziemlich dunkel machen die sache war
allerdings wie bereits gesagt unten
partymeile und so da war es trotzdem
immer noch hart hell mitten in der nacht
das hier ist jetzt ein foto was quasi
von den fenstern aus fotografiert wurde
auf die haustür zu
das lustige war hier seht ihr schon mal
ein kühlschrank das ist nämlich wirklich
mein kühlschrank als wenn ihm manchmal
in meinen früheren videos im hintergrund
gesehen hat man einige leute hey luca
dass er voll den geiern marshall
verstärker darum stehen spielst du warst
oder warum brauchst du denen das war
tatsächlich mein kühlschrank und zwar
war der halt in diesem marshall
verstärker boxen design und die sache
ist eine lustige story dazu wir hatten
den bestellt und ich brauchte den halt
innerhalb von einem monat weil ich halt
eingezogen bin dann in meiner wohnung ja
mal was viel länger gebraucht um dieses
ding irgendwie fertig zu kriegen und mir
rüber zu schicken weil die teile wohl
nicht so oft bestellt werden allesamt
anfertigungen sind oder so deswegen
haben die mir als wiedergutmachung sonne
palette bier mit geschickt und das war
halt so ein lcd starkbier aus england
und es hat so scheiße geschmeckt und das
habe ich dann an karneval einfach
verteilt an leute die bock auf dem bier
hatten also das war auf jeden fall ganz
lustig diese ganzen sachen sind alles
dinge die mir meine mutter gegeben hat
zum einzug also es waren alles
irgendwelche putz sachen jetzt nur noch
mal zur orientierung hier sind die fans
hier ist der eingang und hier um die
ecke ist das hier das ist mein
kleiderschrank gewesen
der hatte eine tiefe von circa 50 cm
würde ich sagen eine breite von einem
meter irgendwas also hier hatte ich alle
meine klamotten drin in der wohnung war
es halt irgendwann so dass ich wirklich
gar kein platz mehr hatte für meine
klamotten und ich einfach sachen die ich
nicht an mindestens einmal die woche
getragen habe einfach gespendet habe
in alt leider für irgendwelche
bedürftige das war wirklich der einzige
platz den ich hatte
ich weiß nicht ob ich noch ein foto
wieder sachen drin waren das hier ist
das einzige foto das ich von meinem
gefüllten kleiderschrank gerade habe
das habe ich leider nicht auf dem pc
mehr klamotten konnte ich in diesen hang
im kleiderschrank halt einfach nicht
rein packen weil der sonst abgerissen
wäre der war nur mit klett oben
festgemacht an sondern garderobenstange
also das war wirklich die komplette
wohnung war ikea 08 15 nimmt man auch
hier so sein dass auf jeden fall aus wo
ich gepennt habe das hier war mein bett
das ging hier dann rüber davon hab ich
glaube ich kein genaues foto und das
hier war halt so ein ikea schrank da
waren meine handtücher drin weil ich im
bad kein platz dafür hatte ich hatte
übrigens auch keine waschmaschine und
einen trockner und keine spülmaschine
mit wäsche et cetera bin ich immer zu
mir nach hause gefahren so sah mein
schreibtisch aus als wären gerade gebaut
hatten und zwar war der auch wieder so
nur das 15 irgendwie zusammen gebaut mit
spanplatten hier haben wir das extra so
abgesägt dass mein kühlschrank darunter
passte weil ich eine küche kein platz
mehr hatte für den kühlschrank die vorne
sieht beim eine couch und zwar war das
wirklich eine couch bestehend aus vier
europaletten die wir kostenlos bei
irgendeiner spedition bekommen haben und
so kissen die wir da drauf gepackt
hatten die hatten meine eltern noch rum
liegen mit einem den teppich den hatten
wir auch noch bei uns im keller also die
kann der komplette couch bereich hat
mich null euro gekostet hier seht ihr
jetzt noch mal den fertigen schreibtisch
beziehungsweise noch einen teil davon
also ich hab dann noch so holz klebe
platten draufgelegt das war kein echtes
holz aber ich hab's halt stand schöner
also ich finde dass das hier schöner
aussieht als dass hier zumindest bei der
softbox habe ich unten diesen drei
beinen standfuß abgeschraubt weil die
softbox ja irgendwie in dieses loch hier
passen musste und da passt halt nur eine
stange durch das war nicht so schön wir
haben diese komplette wohnung so auf den
kopf gestellt und so individuell
gestaltet war eigentlich echt nice und
das hier war dann der fertige
schreibtisch
also mit wirklich hier drucker drauf
hier alles abgeklebt mit holz und hier
halt meinen desktop-pc und mein
bildschirm oder anhalt place etc
hier ist sogar noch mein mitschuld mit
dem ich immer locker gemacht haben
hinsichtlich mucke wollte ich mich
eigentlich schon seit jahren meinen
eigenen songs setzen ja vielleicht mache
ich das bald man irgendwann auf jeden
fall war dass sie meine erste wohnung im
sechsten stock oben am zülpicher platz
es war eine sehr sehr sehr sehr coole
wohnung und es war für mich einfach als
ich diesen bravo artikel zu hause wieder
gefunden habe es war für mich einfach so
einen nostalgie moment wo ich mir
gedacht habe hey ich mache kein visiting
my hometown video ich mache ein visiting
my first flat video wenn euch diese
reise in die vergangenheit sage ich mal
mit mir hier zusammen in meine erste
eigene wohnung gefallen hat dann würde
ich mich sehr sehr dollar einen daumen
hoch von euch freuen wollte eventuell
auch mal bilder aus meiner zweiten
wohnung sehen weil ich habe ja noch nie
aus irgendeiner wohnung irgendeine ruto
hochgeladen schreibt mir das gerne und
in die kommentare peter bock drauf
hättet und schreibt mir auch gerne in
die kommentare ob ihr zu dieser zeit hat
sich in der wohnung da war vor vier
jahren schon abonnenten auf meinem kanal
das würde mich echt mega interessieren
abonniert keinen kanal und keine videos
mehr zu verpassen und jetzt kommt das
auto
[Musik]